This video is made possible by blinkers,
the first hundred people to go to blinkist.com forward slash biographics or
going to get unlimited access for one week just to try it out.
You'll also get 25% off if you want the full membership.
More about that a bit later on,
but for now,
let's just get on with it.
Henry Ford was an American success story through his dog,
perseverance,
engineering,
brilliance,
and innovative production techniques.
He brought an affordable motor vehicle to the masses,
creating an empire in the process,
and yet there were other aspects of the man that didn't really fit comfortably
in to the American icon image from his antisemitism to his vehement opposition
to unions.
Henry Ford was a man who define you to description and in today's buying
graphics video,
we're going to get close and personal with Henry Ford.
Henry Ford was born on July the 30th 1863 in greenfield township,
Michigan.
It was the oldest of five children to William and Mary.
Fort William was an Irish immigrant.
While Mary was a first generation American of Belgian heritage,
the Ford family,
they were middle class farmers.
Henry was particularly close with his mother who he absolutely adored.
The children,
worked hard to help their father performed the day's labor.
Penry pitched in enthusiastically though be never really enjoyed the work he
needs.
A comment says I never had any particular love for the farm.
It was the mother on the farm that I loved and re he disliked school much
preparing to study on his own terms.
He had a huge amounts of curiosity and this was mixed with his creativity.
By the time he had reached his teens and rate was obsessed with gadgets,
he had a habit of taking apart watches and then putting them back together.
He did this over and over again and suddenly you could do it in a matter of
minutes.
His reputation as a watch repairman,
it begins to grow and soon he was maintaining the time pieces of everyone in his
neighborhood.
When he was 13 Henry saw a steam powered motor vehicle for the first time.
He was fascinated with it and he instantly recognized its potential to replace
the horse as the main means of transportation.
From that point on,
he was absolutely obsessed with automobiles.
Yeah.
A short while after the encounter with the vehicle,
Henry's beloved mother,
she died very suddenly.
Naturally Henry was heartbroken from that point on.
He wants it to get off the farm as it simply held.
Too many memories is opportunity.
It came three years later when he was offered his first job.
He moved to Detroit to become an apprentice machinist for James F flower and
brothers who made machine parts.
He laid to move to the Detroit dry dock company by night.
He worked at a watch repair company in order to pay his rent.
Any spare time that he had,
it spends on his mechanical experiments in 1882 at the age of 19 Henry Reed
sounds of the family farm to help his father.
He's still hated farming,
but he loved tinkering with the farm machinery.
His father had purchased a Westinghouse portable steam engine and Henry made it
his mission to perfect the use of it.
They became so good on the machine that he managed to get a summer job at the
Westinghouse Electric Company in Detroit.
He demonstrated and repaired steam engines that we use to power heavy machinery.
When are you turning?
21 of Henry's father gifted him with a sizable parcel of land.
He now splits his time between working the lands,
demonstrating Westinghouse machines and studying part time for a bookkeeping.
To play that in early 1888 he met a young woman by the name of Clara Jen Bryant
after a short courtship.
The couple were married on April the 11th five years later their first and only
child Edsel was born for now.
I had a family to look after.
He made ends meet by cutting and selling the timber on his lambs.
Within a year he set up a saw mill which became moderately profitable.
He built Saint Mechanical Workshop on the farm and it's continued tinkering on
heavy machinery and we had been brought up in Christian households and now that
he was a family man,
he seemed to take religion much more seriously.
Every Sunday.
He made an eight mile round trips.
He attends the nearest Episcopalian church.
He came to believe in reincarnation,
which was not an episcopalian concept rather than finding another church.
However,
he simply added this to his own personal belief system.
He has and evangelizing spirits,
enjoying sharing his beliefs with others and was his religious beliefs.
He wrote religion like anything else is a thing that should be kept working.
I see no use in spending a great deal of time learning about heaven and hell in
my opinion.
Man makes his own heaven and a hell and carries it around with him.
Both of them are states of minds.
In 1885 Ford was tasked with fixing an auto engine,
a large station rate,
single cylinder,
internal combustion,
four stroke engine designs by German Nicolaus Auto.
I've to bullying is a pass and analyzing every components.
He put it back together and working for him and then proceeded to make his own
version of this machine.
By 1890 he was working on a petrol powered engine.
In September of 1891 Henry secured a position at the Edison and illuminating
company in Detroit.
In Gara,
moved to the city to make a new life.
Within two years,
Ford was promoted to the position of chief engineer.
Along with this promotion came a substantial pay rise.
This is provided in the means to work on as petrol engine when he wasn't working
for Thomas Edison in 1896 that countless evenings tinkering in his home
workshop.
They finally paid off with the unveiling of his first self propelled vehicle.
He called it the Ford quadricycle.
He presented his prototype to address and company executives and Keating Thomas
Edison himself.
Addison was intrigued and in fact delighted with Forbes invention encouraged by
the praise of his boss for developed a mark to model with numerous improvements.
Volts newer ends,
better quadricycle caught the attention of a Detroit,
a lumber baron by the name of William H.
Murphy.
Nothing but his money behind the young inventors.
They're allowing Henry to resigned from Edison and start his own company.
He called it the Detroit automobile company.
Investors wanted to capitalize on Ford's petrol motor as quickly as possible.
They pressured him to rush production.
As a result,
the vehicles produced were of a lower quality higher price than photos.
Happy with having produced just 20 automobiles.
The company,
it was dissolved in January of 1901 Ford was more relieved than deterred with
the closure of the Detroit automobile company with the pressure to produce no
longer on him.
He put his efforts into designing and building a 26 horsepower automobile in
October of 1901 in order to get publicity for his invention.
He began entering racing competitions often soundly,
beating the local champion in a 10 mile race.
See one back.
That confidence of his investors,
they were prepared to back a second company and so the Ford Motor Company was
born with Henry as its chief engine.
Yeah.
However,
the same tensions developed as previously when the investors brought in a
consultant to check and Reese focused on technological improvements in half the
company,
the new man,
Henry Leland's when zones to create his own vehicle,
the Cadillac and the company was renamed the Cadillac Automobile Company.
Okay.
Ford now teamed up with a format cycle racing champion named Tom Cooper.
Together they produced an 80 plus horsepower vehicle that they dubbed the nine
nine nine this call was raced by top race and Barry Oldfield to eight resounding
victory in an October of 1902 race with this success under his belt fought,
enters into a third company.
He teams up with a call dealer from Detroit named Alexander Malcolmson to form
forward and Malkin some limited.
He knows that about making an affordable automobile for the working man for to
and Malcolmson.
They found a factory and they got to work.
They contracted the dodge brothers,
John and Horace,
who owns a local machine shop to produce all the parts that they need it within
a year.
Fort had his new an affordable vehicle.
The challenge now is to set it.
Initial sales were slow,
which led to a cash flow crisis.
You invest as well brought on board and the company was reincorporated as the
Ford Motor Company in June of 1903 Fords,
new economical automobile was put to the test on the ice covered surface of
lake.
Some clash between Michigan and Ontario.
It's achieved a new land speed record of 91.3 miles per hour.
That's 146.9 kilometers an hour.
Barney Oldfield been toured the country to demonstrate the calm.
This publicity brought the name Henry Ford to a wide audience.
Sales affords a new car.
They grew by 1905 the company.
It was absolutely thriving forest where the only car manufacturer who we're
catering to the middle classes because of for the automobile it was no longer
just the pay thing for the rich.
Now it was able to be seen as a viable means of transport for pretty much
everybody.
No.
Just before we get into Ford's most notable vehicle,
of course,
the model t,
let me tell you a bit about today's sponsor who make the sort of longer videos
possible and that sponsor is Blinkist look.
Now if you,
if you're watching this channel,
you're probably curious about things.
I mean why else would you commit to to a 20 minute video about Henry Ford and
this is why Blinkist is such a great fit for this very channel.
Blinkist is an APP that takes the best insights and need to know info from
thousands of nonfiction books and condenses them to just 15 minutes that you can
read or you can listen to 8 million people currently use this APP and they're
consuming content.
That's from history to self help.
The way I consume think is that my commute to work is about 15 minutes each way.
So it's perfect for a little hit of knowledge.
Blinkist is about 15 minutes of audio or tax to read.
It's really a way to fast track myself to the most important knowledge from
important books.
One that I recently recapped with Stephen Covey's seven habits.
A book that I've read in the past,
ams love blinkers provided me an amazing reminder of all of the best stuff from
that book,
but it's not a central that I'd read it in the first place,
but this is also a biography channel.
So how about I recommend one of the many books from Walter Isaacson on that
platform.
He's biography,
people like Einstein,
Franklin Da Vinci,
Steve Jobs,
the first hundred people to go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash and
biographic it's going to get unlimited access for one week to try it out.
She wants to get 25% off.
If you want the full membership,
get it now and grab those seven habits or maybe the biography of Einstein or Da
Vinci.
Again,
that's completely free.
Just go to blinkus.com forward slash biographics let's get back to fort.
In October,
1908 Ford released of a famous model t.
This streamlines vehicle has a number of innovative features including having
the steering wheel on the left and entirely enclosed transmission engine four
cylinder is cast in solid block and it's a pair of semi elliptic suspension
springs.
The model t was easier than anything else on the market to drive and it was
inexpensive to repair.
Now with the model t Ford introduced the assembly line production process.
Now.
He wasn't the first to use assembly line production procedures,
but he did refine it to make it as efficient and as therefore as cost effective
as possible.
Rather than having a group of employees working on a single vehicle,
Ford set up a conveyor system where the calm moved from one station to another.
At each station,
a highly skilled worker would focus on just one aspect of the construction.
That worker would then repeat the same job over and over again.
This process cut down the time to produce a model t from 12 to only six hours.
As a result of these improved practices was able to sell his model to you the
unheard of price of $895 which is $23,010 in today's money,
this was less than half of what other manufacturers were selling their vehicles
for.
As the assembly line process was,
streamlines the price of the model t.
It came down even further.
By 1912 it was down to $575 on the strength of the massive popularity of the
model.
T Ford was able to day,
gave 48% share of the u s automobile market.
By 1914 in 1913 though a multistory factory was built in Highland park.
The assembly of the model t would begin on the fourth floor with the engine and
it would move down floor by floor until the body was added on the final and
ground floor for to set up a network of model t franchises all over the country.
Salesman sold and not only the affordable car,
but also the concept of vehicle travel and the opportunities that came with it.
With the model t,
the country would be opened up to the masses with all the wonders that is held
in store.
Ford was determined that his buyers would become loyal fort customers for life.
As a result,
he offered an unheard of guarantee.
When you bought a model t,
the Ford factory would stands behind you maintaining it at the most affordable
price possible.
Ford was a firm believer in welfare capitalism.
He wanted to maintain a happy workforce who were treated fairly.
As a result,
he introduced innovative programs and benefits for his staff.
In 1914 he introduced the living wage where each worker received a minimum of $5
per day.
This would be the equivalent of about $120 in 2019 this is always double the pay
that most other companies were offering at the time.
One reason that Ford brought in the living wage was that prior to its
introduction,
his factories had a very high employee turnover rate.
Some departments numbering a hundred men tons over 30 employees a year.
This was largely due to the monotony of the production line process.
Now,
the increased pay offset the boredom of the job.
The living wage allowed for us to attract the best mechanics in Detroit of the
companies.
They were forced to raise their wages or simply lose their workers for Aussie.
Did other things to ensure a happy workforce is factories.
That cafeteria is water fountains,
healthcare ins company sponsored sports teams.
The benefits that Ford brought to his workforce.
Though they came with a few strings.
He expected his workers live clean lives in accordance with Christian and moral
principles.
He established a social departments which kept a close eye on the private lives
of his employees.
Anyone who was seen to be overdrinking gambling or not providing adequately for
that family would be subjected to an intervention.
Meanwhile,
businesswise cells of the model t we're going from strength to strength and
dropping the price of the basic touring car to $360 saw sales reaching 472,000
in 1916 every single one of those cars was black as was the color that dried the
fastest on the assembly line.
This led forward to to the rather famous line that any customer can have a car
painted any color he wants,
so long as it is black
voted was completely opposed to us participation in world war one he was a
pacifist.
He was offended by other businessmen who profited from war trade.
In 1915 he teams up with Hungarian born Jewish pacifist or seek a Schwimmer and
funded a piece ship to travel to Europe and advocate for an end of the fighting
117 leading pacifists.
It's boarded the ship headed along with Ford and Schwimmer to the Netherlands
and then on to Sweden.
The voyage did not have official US government blessing and it soon became the
subject of intense ridiculed for decided to distance himself from the enterprise
and he left the ship and made his own way back to the United States.
Around this time,
VOD began.
Z make public is antisemitic beliefs.
He claims that the war had been started by German Jewish bankers and that he was
collecting information that would make that fact clear.
Despite its founders pacifist and antisemitic sentiments,
the Ford Motor company was pressed into producing engines for fighter planes and
anti submarine boats.
Once the u s entered the war in 1917 and 1918 at the urging of President Woodrow
Wilson Ford ran for the Senate seat and Michigan Ford was an advocate for
Wilson's League of nations and the president had felt that if Ford won Michigan,
it could tip the scale in his favor and congress.
He told Ford,
you are the only man in Michigan who can be elected and help bring about the
peace you so desire fought.
He ran,
but he lost by about 4,500 votes.
Still,
he did remain a staunch advocate of the League of nations.
A month after the end of the war in December of 19 1940 handed the reigns of the
Ford Motor Company over to his son Edsel,
who is now 26 years old.
However,
the father retains the right to veto any decision.
In 1918 Ford had purchased a small newspaper called the Dearborn independence.
Every Ford factory issued this paper to its employees throughout the 1920s Ford
use this paper as the vehicle for disseminating his antisemitic views.
He believed that an international Jewish conspiracy was walking to take control
of the world.
Between 1920 and 1922 we published a multivolume work titled The International
Jew.
Historians now believe that these books were an influence on ad off Hitler's
worldview during the warriors for worked with his son to take the Ford Motor
Company to the rest of the world.
A massive complex was built at River Rouge in Dearborn,
Michigan.
This was the world's largest industrial complex at the time.
By 1929 he had thriving dealerships on all six continents.
Ford wanted his business to become a vertically integrated company.
This means that every aspect of supply for the company would be owned by the
company.
This meant that the company wouldn't have to rely upon any suppliers,
especially foreign suppliers.
On May the 31st of 1929 Ford signed a nine year technical assistance agreement
with the Soviet government forces would help the Soviets set up an automobile
blinds in the Soviets would purchase $30 million worth of knocked down for
trucks and cars.
Ford sent his best servicemen to the Soviet factory to train the Russians
by the mid 1920s the model t sales,
they would dwindling competitors.
We're producing competing models,
some of them with more powerful motors and better features.
It was time for a new model to roll off the production lines and model.
A Ford was released in 1927 the car was available in a range of styles including
sports could pay truck and it's commercial.
I'm like the model t.
It was available in four colors.
The model a was another hit for Ford with sales to 1931 topping 4 million by
1931 a third of all automobiles throughout the world were made by the Ford Motor
Company.
In the late 1920 Ford began building airplanes.
The most popular was the Ford for 80 try,
Mota,
commonly known as the tin goose fought for.
This was honored by the Smithsonian Institution for changing aviation history.
Henry Ford hated labor unions.
He was of the opinion that they served only the self interest of labor bosses
who were detrimental to workers.
He felt that he was perfectly able to look after the interests of his works and
saw no need for bunions on his sites in order to scare off union activity.
40 employed,
uh,
former navy boxer.
Harry Bennet's had his service department then it was not averse to using
violence to squash union activity.
On one occasion he had men be AARP United autoworkers representatives as the
police simply looked on this incidence,
which became known as the battle of the overpass was widely reported.
It's hard Ford's reputation and it increased support for the union.
Edsel Ford recognized that that was a need for a collective bargaining
agreements with unions.
However,
his father vetoed the idea of him even talking to the unions.
In April,
1941 there was a sit down strike,
which closed down the river rouge plant fort prepared to shut down his entire
business rather than deal with the union.
It was only the intervention of his long suffering wife Plora that brought him
to his senses with the recalcitrants of the old man.
Out of the way,
it's still managed to sign an agreement with the United Auto Workers Union.
In June of 1941
[inaudible] obsession with blaming the Jews for the worlds ills intensified over
the years.
His newspaper,
the Dearborn Independence,
published 91 consecutive articles to writing Jews.
Jewish leaders responded by calling for of Fords cars.
In 1927 he was sued for Lidl,
the case.
It was settled out of court.
Shortly thereafter for degreed to shut down production of his newspaper.
In the early 1920s Ford had been given a copy of a book gold,
the Protocol of the Elders of Zion,
which had been produced by the Russian sauce secret service in the early 19
hundreds it painted a damning picture if the supposed worldwide Jewish
conspiracy fought.
He believed every word of it.
However,
within a few years it was exposed as a fake.
Went forward.
Learned of this.
He was horrified and z often an apology to the Jewish community,
assuring them of his future friendship and goodwill.
Despite these words,
Ford continued to denounce Jews throughout the 1930s he did business with Nazi
Germany up to and including the warriors at the same time he produced be 24
bombers for the u s military.
Ford is the only American mentioned favorably and mine comf speaking in 1931 two
eight Detroit News reporter Hitless ads that he regarded forward as his
inspiration.
This explained his reason for keeping Ford's life size portrait next to his
desk.
Headline reveal at Fort stating that I shall do my best to put his theories into
practice in Germany and modeling the Volkswagen on the model t.
Yeah.
In May,
1943 49 year old Edsel Ford died of stomach cancer.
Henry now aged 80 was forced to run the company one small.
Yes.
He was not a well man.
Having already suffered from a series of strokes and heart attacks.
He was at the helm for two years,
at which point he handed the reins over to his grandson,
Henry Ford.
The second,
Henry Ford's retirement was short lived.
He died of a cerebral hemorrhage on April the seventh of 1947 it is Dearborn,
a state,
100,000 people showed up at his funeral to honor the man who brought private
transportation to the masses.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
As always,
do give us a thumbs up.
Subscribe if you'd like to hit the notification bell so you'll find out when we
put out a new video and also do check out today's sponsor.
That's Blinkist.
You'll find a link to them below.
It's really great stuff.
Just go check it out now before you watch something else,
why not?
And as always,
thank you for watching.